you have tuned in to the sounds of WK &
z the dutch station
you
[Music]
what's going on you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here you sitting there
thinking where's my ship gonna come in
when is my ship gonna comment
guess what [ __ ] it's Tuesday it's
in it's up to you to go out there and
[ __ ] unload that ship twenties
fifties yardsticks are you kidding me or
what we've arrived the clouds around the
haze is over the Sun you think that's
gonna stop me you [ __ ] no there's
Gentiles right now sitting there oh my
god it's such a gloomy day I [ __ ] it I
go off on [ __ ] gloomy days these are
my [ __ ] days because everybody's
focused on note I give a [ __ ] another
part is when your wallets gonna come out
of your [ __ ] pocket you gonna lay
those 20s on that's all that matters
today that suckers it's a beautiful bed
of be alive rain snow sleet Godzilla
comes out of the ocean I don't give a
[ __ ] you gotta go out there lay some
[ __ ] dick you gotta set your marker
and enforce it [ __ ] huh wait
I'm [ __ ] sitting here talking to
myself [ __ ] no it's Tuesday
that's so much meat at the barbecue yeah
I don't give a [ __ ]
take a [ __ ] it even Apple [ __ ]
smoothie and go [ __ ] it out it's a
beautiful [ __ ] day we've gotta get
out there make it happen you understand
me ain't nobody gonna come into your
living room with a [ __ ] envelope it's
for you cuz you're so special you wear
that [ __ ] shirt this is free China I
don't give a [ __ ] free Tibet I'm too
[ __ ] Tibet nobody gives a [ __ ]
bunch of [ __ ] skirts in shoot I mean
that 20 years ago Free Tibet but free
Noriega them gives a [ __ ] about the best
I gotta sit there with a bunch of monks
philosophize meanwhile I got sandals on
and I got no pockets what the [ __ ] you
talkin to me about I might have banging
out with these gorillas on the [ __ ]
Bailey at the Comedy Store
last night people cried I'm [ __ ]
believable where's Tommy Easter when you
need a bitch-slap and [ __ ]
karate-chopping [ __ ] anyway it's that
type of day a little [ __ ] anger to me
I don't know working out - hey I'm Joe
Rogan podcast I got some acupuncture and
I got a spot at The Comedy Store tonight
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do your life
sitting there could take it me yeah
you're feeling a little hump today I
don't really want to go together go to
work you gotta go to work every [ __ ]
day seven days a week you got to do what
the other guy is [ __ ] doing you
understand me always remember that he's
gotta be doing with the other guy when
you have a song he's at home scratching
his [ __ ] mind [ __ ] himself with
marina
oh my god they caught another shark off
the coast of who gives a [ __ ] sharks are
hungry really [ __ ] hungry the Sharks
are [ __ ] enlighten people cuz they
bought down there they really bite some
of these [ __ ] [ __ ] my advice
don't [ __ ] stay on the beach put on
number four and just walk on the side
like black people you ever seen he was
gonna beat you Miami black people under
the [ __ ] trees he should bet I'm
gonna get hit by the [ __ ] Sun same
[ __ ] your walk on a beach real lightly
the Sharks won't bother you never see
some white people coming up saying I got
the bash on [ __ ] on in my net business
they know it's dangerous out there
it's you [ __ ] Gentiles I wanna go out
there I'm gonna take my paddle boat get
the [ __ ] out a little pool
oh well it was Clouds of Joy this reef
is on [ __ ] fire today understand I
got some [ __ ] exclusive durable
ba-bop ba-bop up my pants huh look at
people writing to me and [ __ ] Arabic
I like it I don't know what it says but
I like it it probably says ah the one
eyed you is coming snake pops up the
[ __ ] snake
imagine having a flute with a [ __ ]
snake all day you're in your office it
was comes in to get tomorrow you have to
[ __ ] a snake stop if they run out of it
I never get me a snake make a note cut
suckers don't you sit there watch it
it's Tuesday okay I know you're feeling
sucked up and viewing that time to feel
[ __ ] up you ain't got time to bleed
you'll you'll bleed when you die as that
you gotta go out there today you know
look people in the eye you gonna say
suck my [ __ ] balls you understand me
it's tools they don't give a [ __ ]
seven days a week 24/7 with that's the
mental state everybody oh my god that
barbecued is a [ __ ] are we the [ __ ]
scab I stay home by myself and meditate
with a summons with the [ __ ] same
I'm just sitting here talking to myself
listen get up get out there make it
happen - they're right you ain't got
time to [ __ ] around ain't got time to
play table these guys point down to
somebody's [ __ ] there why's that here
look but look there's a [ __ ] me my your
wife is bent over the [ __ ] is wrong with
these people
pay attention keep your eyes open and
only deal with what's in front of you
you understand me everybody who gets
blown up because they're doing something
is supposed to be doing that well it's
kind of the parking for frisbees get the
[ __ ] outta here
smoke some leafless they hope I write a
[ __ ] paragraph about throwing
frisbees as their mind your [ __ ]
business
it's Tuesday we ain't [ __ ] around
play the church we got none today I'll
be on the Joe Rogan podcast I'll uh what
else would I be doing today I'm at the
store I gotta get acupuncture you know
big dog you gotta take care of the
[ __ ] physique of a fat [ __ ] I got a
deflate they put mm needles I start
losing air anyway have a great day don't
take [ __ ] from nobody today you're on a
mission from [ __ ] Satan you
understand me [ __ ] Joel Olsteen is
[ __ ] can't tell you a way to like
listen you ain't tiptoeing know where
you're coming out with a big dick of a
[ __ ] happy birthday ahead onions them
every day's your [ __ ] birthday just
think about that that way but don't
imagine if every day is your [ __ ]
birthday and reality it is every day's
your birthday you're smoking your token
you're [ __ ] doing work it don't
matter it's always a beautiful day to be
alive
I'll see you [ __ ] today and
11:00 a.m. with Joe Rogan tomorrow three
and three o'clock in the afternoon we're
starting off early June first means
[ __ ] around with different sort of
mattresses you understand me
I love you [ __ ] stay black oh
yeah they did open go on hey Coco our
Dean is hindered AOA hair matted at my
dinner on eco Hornet forget Martin was a
complete a great man was told me that
stay black
uncle Joey loves you
and we'll talk today at lunch time I'm
Jie [ __ ]